le programme que nous présentons ces
journées est un programme de saisie des
éléments des différents éléments d'un
dossier de médicale permettant aux
médecins de faire entrer en mémoire ces
différents critères qui par la suite
permettront une exploitation
statistiques des dossiers des malades
ça s'adresse donc un soin des médecins
praticiens libéraux soient des médecins
travaillant en groupes ou en hôpital
concrètement quels usages pourront-ils
enfer donc concrètement au fur à mesure
de sa consultation le médecin fait
rentrer en mémoire dans l'ordinateur
les différents éléments qu'ils jugent
nécessaires à la tenue de son dossier
par la suite
tous ces éléments serviront de critères
de tri de critères de choix à une étude
statistique sur l'ensemble de la
population de ces patients l'intérêt
c'est de leur donner un outil de travail
nouveau sirh que la médecine ne veut pas
être transformé par l'informatique sera
toujours avec les mains avec les
oreilles avec les yeux et puis avec le
cerveau on écoutera toujours autant les
patients en fournissant un ordinateur
aux médecins on va peut-être leur
permettre de mieux compenser leurs
dossiers stères de pouvoir surtout faire
parce qu'on appelle de l'épidémiologie
pouvoir
par exemple chaque mois analysé les
patients qu'ils ont vu et surtout chaque
année et peut-être dans ces domaines
voir si une pathologie particulière
apparaît et leur donner les moyens de se
former et de s'informer dans le domaine
de cette pathologie c'est à dire un
meilleur exercice médical non pas pour
le malade mais pour les malades et qui
bien sûr aura des retombées individuel
[Musique]